first of all your hair is I think it
beats my hair guys hair but also I have
to compliment you you were in the most
amazing shape I talked to everybody in
this business
this guy is 52 years old and he has 5
percent body fat 5 percent that's insane
good for me and it's I look really sexy
naked you look sexy name see that's
where we're different
I am 54 years old and 80 percent body
fat yeah I have no skeleton is really I
came back and at the same time you came
back oh really were there with me yeah
yeah it was amazing had you ever been
before I had never been to Israel I was
my croissant
oh yeah yeah wait way to go Israel yeah
it's so interesting when someone
compliments me on my body which never
happens I don't then change the subject
I keep it on my body rather talk about
Israel then lie about your body fat
alright let's talk about this I want to
talk about your fighting skills you are
a very good fighter there are a lot of
people that play fighters or pretend to
be fighters you're the real deal you
like it right I like that yeah yeah you
get your aggressions out when you fight
I do I I train every day and it is it's
a part of my my therapy I think what do
you eat if you're a 5% body fat what are
you eating
nothing I'm starving yeah no I eat you
know I eat a lot of like grass-fed meats
and and fresh-caught fish and nuts and
you know the Paleo thing about doing it
for years you have like you're like lost
in the woods that's how I like a caveman
I'm right
you